[Applaudissements]
bon allez semaines numéro 3 j'espère
juste que tu t'entends pas à ce que je
parle des excroissances ma mère de kate
middleton
non parce que moi je connais un bon
dermato en trois secondes il enlève ce à
quoi
vous commencez à ouais tu savais toi que
les musulmans étaient obligés d'acheter
charlie hebdo non non tout ce cirque sur
les dessins du prophète dans la mesure
où personne ne l'a jamais vu qu'est ce
qui nous dit que charlie est forcément
dans la caricature
non salafistes faut pas déconner c'est
quoi c'est un type qui est juste pas
assez doué pour faire dealer quoi
attention je dis ça je suis pas là pour
critiquer les dealers à samedi soir à 3h
du mat à paris c'est peut-être les seuls
mecs qui sont sobres
et moi je comprends leur malaise je
comprends leur malaise les pauvres tu
vois ils sont manifestés plein 8e
arrondissement entouré de boutiques pour
[ __ ] des petites femmes qui
déambule et dont les plus pudiques sont
à peine recouvertes d'un képi
non franchement lâché un salafiste en
occident sera être aussi angoissant que
parachute est un boulimique au darfour
quoi c'est un peu
tout cas moi quand je vois la débauche
d'énergie qui met les salafistes pour
faire la promo d'un film qui détestent
qu'est ce qui nous aurait cassé les
couilles s'il l'avait aimée
non mais ça fait beaucoup réagir cette
histoire de film tout ça alors la tante
elle plus violent a eu lieu à kaboul
au moins une bonne nouvelle quoi en
afghanistan et sont la fibre optique
pays pauvres mais connectés quoi
par toute façon vous savez que les états
unis vont bientôt réagir quoi il feinte
obama a pris des mesures de rétorsion
ils sortent une version en blu ray
alors évidemment des gens qui
s'engouffre dans la brèche pour en
parler est un forfait à véronique genest
tout de suite fait j'avais dit que je
n'ai situant pc il résume moore après un
avc quoi ce truc
alors elle a dit que la lu le coran bon
sens et tf1 un repère d'intello qu'il
faut arrêter quoi tu vois
alors on se dit que le fn va récupérer
bien évidemment mais le fn comment dire
c'est un parti bon le fn pour moi et aux
électeurs ce que la voiture brûlée et
aux voyous quoi ça sert à rien mais ça
défoule
journée
mais géographiquement
je suis papa je suis pas partiel je vais
dire géographiquement c'est intéressant
le vote fn concerne surtout le vaucluse
et le gard l'ancienne zone libre
je dis ça je dis rien attention ce
parent alors on a beaucoup entendu
marine le pen ou alors les députés vous
avez élu des députés mais
c'est à croire que pour qui la boucle il
suffit de les élire quoi ces gens n'y a
plus personne toute façon si le danger
c'est les deux élus que vous avez enfin
j'veux pas
non mais gilbert collard et marion
maréchal confort le vergès du pauvre et
la pom-pom girls de la garrigue sais pas
mais au moins vous êtes perspicace sans
franchement 1 vous avez tout de suite
compris qu'avec le nombre de vieux
dégueulasse qui à l'assemblée faut
mettre une protection juridique pour la
petite quoi
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai juste regardé je l' ai vu faire
marion à l'assemblée quoi sur des
paroles comme une déléguée de la classe
va vers quoi va arriver là à mettre sa
trousse hello kitty fin je veux dire
c'est alors marion tu en penses quoi de
la csg à moi je suis content sauf en cas
de viol
[Rires]
mais
cela dit cela dit moi je trouve que
c'est bien qu'ils aient plus de femmes à
l'assemblée quoi s'est vu le bordel
actuel ça prouvera qu'elle sont aussi
incompétente que les hommes
[Applaudissements]
sortez de la bien-pensance
s'assurer des choses plus graves des
choses beaucoup plus graves pendant ce
temps qu'est ce qui fait notre kim
jong-il nationale
s'enflamme sur le gaz de schiste
vraiment l'extraterrestre ce mec le
jacques chirac de la fracture géologique
quoi j'ai vu ça alors la droite en face
l'ump cherche leur petit mâle dominant
tu vois le ferez mieux de résoudre le
truc à la loyale tu vas sur champ de
mars un combat de boxe entre copé et
fillon le charlie oleg des kermesses
contre la béquille du septième plus loin
le truc
à cette préoccupation la présidentielle
moi je comprends pas cette obsession
d'être président soit présidente c'est
comme un des rares postes où tu es sûr
qu'une fois élu tu seras impopulaire tu
m'étonnes que xavier bertrand se
précipitent
évidemment on essaie de faire diversion
on essaie de faire ça c'était le grand
truc là dix ans après le mariage gay le
droit de vote des étrangers
donc contrairement à ce que j'ai dit la
semaine passée en ce moment chez psa les
seuls qui ont de l'espoir ce sont les
ouvriers aux maux qui ont un projet de
mariage et dont l'un des conjoints est
un extra communautaires qui rêvent
d'élire un conseiller municipal
marc soir dans le sens que cela va se
bousculer au portillon peut aller mecs
vont être façon cette histoire de
mariage ça continue de faire polémique
barbara l'archevêque qui a déclaré que
le mariage gay c'était la porte ouverte
à l'inceste et à la polygamie enfin
c'est plutôt un argument pour
et se taper sa mère c'est quand même une
des rares opportunités de prendre du
recul avec l'endroit d'où l'on vient
peut-être qu'elle n'était pas efficace
aux pieux avec vous quand j'en sais rien
alors évidemment l'église c'est
vachement opposé super réac l'église ans
et s'oppose au mariage tout ça parce que
deux homosexuels n'arrive pas à se
reproduire
laisser leur a peu de temps
dire qu'elle manque de confiance dans la
théorie de l'évolution naturelle quoi ça
bon je fais un peu moins le malin
aujourd'hui parce que impressionné il ya
un prof parminou quoi
j'ai entendu à des rumeurs sur les profs
passé c'est vrai que vous devez passer
cinq jours par semaine six heures par
jour avec des gosses
vous n'avez pas le droit d'en tuer un
pour l'exemple
hélas
alors quoi d'autre bon le week-end
dernier on avait le chantre la fête de
l'huma ou les journées du patrimoine
évidemment je suis allé aux journées du
patrimoine tu me connais la fête de
l'huma moi je peux je peux pas quoi
quand même le seul festival où entre
deux morceaux de rock et un gros lourd
qui vient de parler du traité de
maastricht voiture
il ya une bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle
qu'a bernard tapie là qui a acheté une
maison à 45 millions je trouve ça bien
enfin enfin un homme politique qui a
réussi sans magouille
alors est pas belle la vie et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus